there's a monitor lizard right there
on that termite Mound
just basking in the Sun
[Music]
they can either play dead
or they can
run like Grease Lightning
let me see if I can get a better look at
it
I can see that this monitor could use a
little help
it's actually kind of good that I found
you because I'll be real gentle oh yeah
you're grabbing a hold you're starting
to wake up
but here's what I want to do see all
these look at these horrible ticks they
get these parasites on them
and they just suck their blood
that's uh make your day
so much better by getting rid of some of
these nasty parasites
nobody likes ticks
including myself
monitors have powerful jaws that can
Crush bones and even through hard shells
of turtles
and have special toxins in their saliva
that stop blood from coagulating
this is just a baby
they can get pretty easily six feet long
so they're the biggest lizard in Africa
and they can defend themselves with
those big sharp claws with a very
powerful bite you can see those big
claws
built for climbing trees built for
climbing termite mounds and built for
grabbing a hole to the ground when it's
in a dead Sprint
they have a fork tongue that's a lot
like a snake they can sort of smell or
sense the air
well this was a really really lucky find
but I'm just gonna let you go right
where I found you
pretty smart lizard
cool
[Music]